foreign
teaser it was confirmed that June will
return as a playable character in Tekken
8.
not only that but a lot of questions has
been answered on what really happened to
her as many presumed her death after the
Tekken 2 games in this video we'll get
to know more about June Kazama as she
makes her way back to Tekkit
[Music]
I want you to begin investigating the
Mishima conglomerate there's a
possibility that producing bioweapons in
direct violation of the Darwin treaty
close that same dark awful feeling
it was no coincidence that we got these
invitations they know exactly who we are
and what we do
if we're careless this invitation could
be a flattering one-way ticket to head
you don't know me and I don't know what
you want but you can't change my mind
tomorrow I'm killing my father
stay out of my way or you will die as
well
if you save your father then my death
was worth it
why are you risking your life for a man
you'll never know I'll kill you
[Music]
thank you
Mama chin
[Music]
the wind just changed what's the matter
nothing everything is fun
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
so what do you think will June put an
end to the rivalry or will this be the
end of Tekken comment your answers below
and make sure to subscribe too
[Music]